les cheminots les cheminots de
versailles c'est la base actuelle le
parti communiste prépare comme chaque
année sa vente traditionnels de brins de
muguet dans les yvelines les adhérents
jouent les apprentis fleuristes et
prépare les commandes de chaque section
ça permet tous les ans de rencontrer des
gens on voit pas spécialement dans nos
locaux mais qui viennent à notre
rencontre
ils nous connaissent 18 sections des
yvelines vendront leurs projets de
demain
la fédération a commandé entre sept et
dix palettes car cette vente représente
une source de revenus non négligeable
pour le parti le parti communiste n'a
pas les mêmes moyens que les gros partis
politiques qui engrange énormément
d'argent vers les fonds publics
des brins politique qui pourront être
accompagnées de roses rouges
alors pour se différencier des ventes
sauvages tolérer le 1er mai les
fleuristes joue la carte de la qualité
donc nous entends floris pas notre rôle
c'est de rester sur une qualité
exemplaire donc pour ça et c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué et il faut faire
très très attention lors de nos achats
la météo humide et fraîche puis très
chaude à abîmer les brins de muguet
coupée sur les halles de rungis où se
fournissent les professionnels ont
dénombré huit cent mille points de moins
que l'année précédente
cette année le muguet se vendra donc
avec racines pour qu'il soit beau au
niveau des clochettes vous voyez elles
sont bien blanche
il ya encore du bouton et puis sont pas
transparents du tout donc c'est cette
voie là ça cela nous avons eu gay ça
qu'elle est un brin communiste ou des
racines pour une qualité irréprochable
les clochettes du muguet sonneront la
fête du travail et le retour du
printemps demain dans toutes les villes